So I am here hanging out in the can am while the kids are practicing
and just wanted to hop on here and talk about protein powder launch.
So our protein powder, farmer protein,
launched last week, and it's been so fun,
you guys, like,
getting this over the finish line
and seeing you open it and drink it and love it
has been literally so fun for all of us on the team.
Especially Daniel and I were just.
It's been a project, dream project for us for, like.
We started dreaming about it two years ago,
and then we started working on it a year ago,
so it's been a long time coming,
which is so cool.
Maple Cinnamon is sold out.
The rumors are true.
Um, but we are getting more in a few weeks.
I would say
snag up the chocolate and vanilla if you are wanting to try,
because we will be sold out for a little bit,
so snag it up when you. If there is some left on the website,
but more is coming. So good.
And I just.
I love you guys. This is half a heart.
If I had my other hand, I would do another heart. You guys are the best.